[Música]
frente a la costa de cerdeña este lugar
es un secreto bien guardado
agostino search y se pone en guardia
para proteger su trocito de paraíso
porque lo que recoge en el fondo del
océano vale su peso en oro el coral rojo
un tesoro increíblemente rentable pero
también peligroso te extraer
muchos pescadores mueren mientras bucean
no hay lugar para los errores también
hay que tener cuidado con el estilo de
vida no se puede beber ni fumar
el coral rojo solo se pescan cuatro
meses al año para evitar la
sobreexplotación
equipado con un hacha agostino solo
recoge piezas adultas
porque los corales se toman su tiempo
para florecer sólo crecen un centímetro
cada diez años su escasez es lo que hace
que el coral sea tan valioso
tengo un kilo un kilo y medio
vale 300 mil quinientos euros más o
menos para los pescadores el coral rojo
es oro
tras una exitosa excursión los
pescadores regresan al cairo en el
noroeste de cerdeña la capital del coral
rojo
desde la antigüedad la ciudad costera ha
sacado provecho de los tesoros del mar
decenas de artesanos transforman aquí el
precioso material en obras de arte
con esta desempleo una cola nadando de
milímetro de diámetro
las perlas son de 12 milímetros de
diámetro son de muy alta calidad el
cierre es de coral y oro cuesta 36 mil
euros
carmela es una de las creadoras más
reputadas de la ciudad
su pequeño taller se encuentra en la
parte trasera de la tienda
el proceso creativo es largo meticuloso
y requiere una precisión quirúrgica
la idea precisa antes de empezar hay que
tener una idea clara de cómo se quiere
que sea la escultura terminada se
necesitan dos días para hacer un
querubín como éste
pero el arte está en peligro ya que
algunas tiendas están vendiendo
imitaciones estos productos parecen
atractivos para los consumidores y sus
carteras pero las señales son engañosas
están hechos de un coral blanqueado
llamado bambú que no tiene ningún valor
y se importa de china el gerente de esta
tienda de souvenirs no ve el problema
tenemos coral zardo pero como es un
producto de lujo lo ponemos en las
vitrinas del fondo no vamos a mostrarlo
demasiado todo lo que ves son souvenirs
no están hecho del mismo coral y esto es
evidente cuando miras el precio una
pulsera pequeña cuesta tres euros
[Aplausos]
vito torres presidente de la asociación
de artesanos de algueró no está de
acuerdo
tiene una fácil
como espera que un turista entienda la
diferencia no es fácil un experto lo ve
enseguida e incluso entonces para los
objetos más pequeños no es obvio
siguientes coral de bambú tienes que
apartarlo es decir que está tratado de
coloreado en otro lugar
[Música]
los artesanos locales han creado una
etiqueta para proteger el tesoro de los
pescadores como agustín o no se les
permite vender coral rojo fuera de esta
ciudad costera